sex is kind of overrated y'all I'm just
saying sex is like Cooperative Fitness
you know it's a great workout it's good
cardio I don't need it
[Music]
I fell in love quickly
three two one go
I care on that side yeah
how far do I go though what's going
through your mind
a lot of stuff yeah like you know if I
was like six feet tall I kind of just
lay on my side right here and like take
this whole row but like every time I'd
hear
that phrase of
um you know I still haven't been able to
say it throughout my entire life even
when like my family say it to me or my
friends would say it to me or when my
partner would say to me I didn't despite
all the training I've done of watching
movies I still don't register or follow
with like what love means you know what
ah here we go
lay down right here actually this floor
is dirty I'm good
you were talking about not experiencing
what love is supposed to be and I feel
like I caught you in a mental trap that
I spent like years in the thing with
media and music and like movies is that
were told like this is what
neurotypicals experience and this is the
peak of existence and there's no
supposed to whatever you feel and brings
you Joy is your path and that's one of
the things that makes our love so unique
actually that that's I I kind of feel
like because I think what I've talked
very earlier about I'm more of a shower
than a teller like these words of
affirmations like saying things like I
miss you it's things that I'm not very
strong at talking about and More in my
actions I can show things that I care
about you
you know like
I'll bring you food yes or I will
I will hug you harder and I'll be like I
got you girl
I feel like I definitely found strong
feelings for him quickly you
um did things that were very difficult
to ignore like write me love poems and
share them on stage
just how I did it
I'm not on strongly agree because
we're still figuring out what these
feelings mean so I I'm hesitant to fully
be vulnerable thank you yeah hesitant to
fully be vulnerable and it's not a bad
thing yeah
yeah so you kind of agree ing yes I
think being on a spectrum sometimes we
just
love bomb I would like write him letters
I was like probably way too much at the
beginning like obsessiveness I was just
like yeah her eyes immediately
around a month into a stating we were
just like talking in and out and I um I
fell asleep and he just like let me like
sleep with like my head in his lap and I
was like
I want to be with him forever but I just
kept that to myself because no one says
that a month in
my partner wants more physical intimacy
than me
three two one
in Tennessee okay we've got a huge split
here between China
well it's not that I don't like physical
intimacy but I know clearly Rey
definitely likes it more than I do yeah
I I did lack a lot of physical intimacy
since in my childhood I learned physical
affection more through fists than hugs
what did caught me more was that there's
a certain way that Ray hugged
me differently than the way that I
naturally got hugs and I'm like this
feels really
warm and nice
um I don't like getting naked I I feel
like
sex is kind of overrated y'all I'm just
saying sex is like Cooperative Fitness
you know it's a great workout it's
pretty good options like it ain't a bad
thing it's a pretty great thing
I don't need it
yeah so that's that's a balance that's
hard that's hard to maintain sometimes
um
I've definitely had to tone back my
desire for for physical interactions I
get a lot of those needs met through
hand-holding and hugging so I'm like
basically always
hugging chai
it's funny like when I first asked Ray
may I place my hand into your hand or
can I run my face into your face because
I didn't know
um like how to because consent is
important y'all like you know got to get
that consent I need the verbal cues to
be like am I uh may I have your
permission to do the things I'm about to
do to you
so that's kind of what needed a lot if
she says I'm feeling it I'm like I got
you and she says I'm not feeling it I'm
gonna turn off it seems that there's a
lot of commonalities here I've literally
heard her say some of the same words you
just said she's like you know okay give
me your hand i'm gonna put my hand in
your hand now and I'm like you don't
gotta ask for that
and she's like okay I'm gonna hug you
I'm my babe you might like you like my
whole wife
uh awkward thing for me with when it
comes to
physical because I still to this day I
asked for consent a lot of times because
it just doesn't come naturally I don't
know I'm like in the middle because
sometimes I'm over stimulated so he
might try to give me affection I might
be like ah you know right now is not a
good time my youngest is the the same
way we get over stimulated really easily
so she's like don't touch me don't hug
me you know but sometimes I need a lot
of affection I'm like this come on like
you know comfort me I need comforting
and other times I'm like uh you know
this is too much I don't need that right
now like I mean I experience a lot of
over stimulation that basically makes me
more inclined to like set my skin on
fire than this is to to want to like be
like in a like a romantic like touching
situation sometimes I I struggle with
the question I guess because it's not me
that's just like how my body reacts to
my environment it's it's not something
like I identify with it's just if
anything it's just a cause for for
annoyance which is something that I that
I try not to do because that really just
makes it worse but generally I consider
myself in like spirit and personality
like I love affection I love physical
intimacy it's it's really good and it
helps my heart like heal in many many
ways so I was nervous to join this
relationship
three two one
I wasn't necessarily looking for a
relationship and I was not aware that
chai was on the Spectrum
until we started dating
I I just thought he was awkward
I mean that's still true which is still
true
for me I immediately knew that the
relationship was going to be more
difficult than I thought it was going to
be but it wasn't uh oh a make or break
deal this was also my first relationship
and you know Ray gave me something that
not a lot of socially awkward
introverted guys with low self-esteem is
that was you know attention and
affirmation you know kind of the double
a batteries for people with low
self-esteem
I forgot what the problem does oh
nervous yeah oh yeah also nervous
just like how I'm doing it right now um
it's it's hard because it's a brand new
experience for me I didn't know what I
was doing I'm just let's go and see what
happens
I'd love to hear from on this side we
have some disagrees well I'm dyslexic so
I read the science wrong oh no I'm on
the wrong side go for it
oh I was gonna say I somewhat agree
um at the time when I met Terry I was in
the military and I didn't know I was on
the Spectrum but I knew there was
something going on so I was somewhat
nervous because I was afraid that he was
gonna think I'm a little weird or
different because I already knew that I
am very different than the you know
neurotypical person the craziest thing
was we discovered her autism after we
discovered our children's
because it was just like wait a minute
you did that and and you do that and you
talk like that and you you know I was
like
oh wow like and we just started to
educate educate educate so I strongly
disagree and and some of the you know if
we want to describe it as quirkiness
that's what made me fall in love with
her so I was very rigid Stern strong
cold she was very you know what are you
talking about let go you know and
eventually I was able to just let go
so I think I definitely gained from
being in a relationship with her
so I strongly agreed because there was
something so J
en like registered to me at first that
he was autistic to the day he told me he
loved me I told my best friend and she
was like well like what does he want I
was like I don't know
but since then it's been incredible and
he's created such a safe environment for
me and it's it's the best relationship
and I love him very much so
I remember when we first met we were at
a park with a bunch of people we barely
knew and you're both stressed about that
and we like the first time I even caught
her eye we gave each other like a
stressed out side glance from being in a
social situation and like yeah yeah
because I tend to I've always gravitated
towards people who are not like who are
not neurotypical and you know like she's
this she's not normal but it's okay
it's okay there's nothing wrong with
that we had talked a lot about like
wanting to find people like how he'd
wanted to find someone that we could
like open up to
um in the face of uh trauma that we both
experienced and it was at that point I
was like okay like the nervousness will
have to come to an end and I think this
is the person that I want to like
retrain my brain into like doing that
with
I want kids on the Spectrum
go
all right we have kids on the Spectrum I
know
um
if I were to like design a baby I would
I would make changes I'm also an
engineer and there are things that like
in my life that like I don't feel
attached to and if I could I would
change just from like a genetics point
of view
so
um
I don't see
that there's any fault in being on the
spectrum because this disability is just
that Society sees as our inability to
communicate or talk to people that
portray our intelligence not by our
minds but by the way we speak
why wouldn't you want like to love your
kids rather they're on the Spectrum or
any Spectrum or any sexuality any race
gender or however
I suppose mostly my I strongly disagree
comes from what the way the world is
kind of seeming like going now for our
future Generations
so that's more like uh don't kids
I mean uh probably not really
we have children on the Spectrum
and uh man
um being with Ayumi and having kids to
discover that has literally changed my
life it's changed my patience it's
changed my observations of self it's
changed all of the trauma that I grew up
with you know like although it is
definitely a learn as you go experience
and I definitely don't have you know a
closet full of all wins
you know I definitely am grateful for
that opportunity they are amazing like
literally the most talented little girls
ever I I do feel you know sad because
they do have challenges with making
friends and not being able to I guess be
the neurotypical kid and being able to
understand directions right away
so I I do have to think like do I want
another child to you know have to go
through that so I say somewhat agree
because there's a lot of challenges that
I had to go through that my kids are
going through so but amazing people
little humans
I have felt difficult to love
three two one
okay I'm gonna make sure I the question
is correct okay
I just
feel like there's a lot of
things I I have going on like low
self-esteem extremely
um
over stimulated and um
yeah I think you might want to come over
here
so you're saying you feel hard
oh no oh
man can we start all over
sorry mine's not long okay we tell I
teleported on this we're sorry unlovable
I'll start for the top okay so yes I do
feel like I'm very difficult to love
it's hard to be vulnerable
and being on the Spectrum on top of that
is just hard for me to communicate or I
might overreact you know it just I feel
like more than the typical person I have
a lot more things going on so I'm just
like why would somebody love me when I
have
all these things I can't even follow
simple directions or I can't even
communicate something so I just feel
like I have lots of obstacles
first I'm going to say that this room
should be a living example of our belief
that we're difficult to love is not real
because everyone probably thinks that
way to some degree and she's easy to
love she's a great mom and I can sit up
here and talk for hours about why I do
love her and how easy it is but I also
understand she does have the challenges
that she mentioned but so do I I also
agree that I'm difficult to love even
though I would hope that she disagrees
but um you know if you choose to love me
you know love me for my strengths and
help me through my weak weaknesses so
um
funny for me like holding Connor Santa
being like I feel hard to love but
autism itself is not the reason for that
for me it's other disorders that like
because I experience a lot of
dysregulated emotion like unpredictable
waves of rage and paranoia and just
things that I think would be stressful
for a person
to deal with being with me
but Conor has been very patient and I
want to make him as happy as I possibly
can even in the midst of my
challenges
for me finding her hard to love isn't
something that I think about it's not
something that I experience I find her
easy to love because I love her a lot
but in my personal experience like the
way my brain seems to work is that like
if my brain's in the mood to perceive
myself as like not likable or unlovable
it immediately summons the ghosts of
everyone in my life that I've ever
thought displayed that kind of reaction
to anything that I may or may not have
done and so like I've had much more
experience in that realm than I have in
the self-help like self-love like Oh I'm
great like I'm doing good it's been an
effort for me to try to retrain my brain
to do less of that for less amount of
like the time that I'm alive and awake
so damn love it love is pretty darn hard
like yeah I don't see how anyone could
have figured this thing out so many
people feel alone when they're not alone
like you see how lonely that side is and
how unlonely this side is to feeling
like that we are alone like how could
this be we're all sitting on the same
line we can't fit on the same line like
y'all would have been right here but
like there's it's just not enough room
for people to be alone you know yeah I
really want to be in this line
but I'm in this line because even though
I've I've expressed
um feeling uh not safe or feeling lonely
or feeling like I don't know who to turn
to or who will accept me I know that
these feelings are
transitions
and there's something that I need to
find for myself within them I'm trying
to get over there or
yes over there
um
and uh
really grateful to try for helping me
get to that direction
well guys this was an amazing
conversation this is a wrap
you are all set
thank you guys so much
[Music]